[Music]
welcome everybody thanks for coming I
know the day's been running a little bit
long so I will hopefully not keep you
too long
welcome to the session between you and
happy hour hopefully we'll get you out
of here just in time to get some drinks
and get some snacks my name is Sandeep
Parikh
I run the cloud solutions architecture
team for America's East for Google cloud
platform and today I want to talk to you
about building a collaborative data
platform right effectively you've got
teams of individuals spread across your
company that have to work together in
some meaningful way and you need them to
share data talk to each other basically
build something together so how do you
enable that so we're gonna walk through
some of the ways that we tell a lot of
customers and developers and partners
how to do that stuff in the real world
first we're gonna meet our hypothetical
team of individuals and we're gonna
learn about the tasks they have to do
and the tools that they typically use
and then we'll jump into mapping the
tools they use - the tools available in
Google cloud so you can start to see how
they might get a consistent set of tools
and work together and then we're gonna
talk about how we enable collaboration
right this is how we do things like set
up teams to do you know self-service and
easy data discovery I'm probably going
to trivialize a handful of details but
stay with me it'll it'll make sense as
we get through it and then I want to
cover what the new workflow likes once
you get all this stuff up and running
and then give you a couple little things
and tips on how to get started does that
make sense to everybody head nods ok
good all right let's meet the team all
right so first we've got about 4
individuals we've got a data scientist a
data engineer business analysts and an
app developer ultimately they all have
three things in common they use
different data sets those data sets are
all in different formats and they all
use different tools right so there's not
a ton of overlap here and that's kind of
the challenge so let's assume for a
second or let's imagine for a second
we've got this team and their job is to
build a recommendation engine for a
retail site so what are the kinds of
things that each person on the team is
gonna need to be successful in order to
do their job so the first thing we'll
cover is the data and then we'll talk
about the tools
so from a data perspective Alice the
data scientist needs kind of cleansed
normalized data right things that have
no longer log files right not just raw
rows from a database but things that
actually makes sense and those could be
you know for example stuff like Purchase
History Product history product metadata
click streams product reviews right all
the stuff that it would take to actually
craft and model a recommendation problem
then we've got Bob the data engineer
right he's gonna have to take all of the
raw data and turn to something useful so
he's probably gonna need things like
logs information product transactions or
Purchase History
Product metadata as well this is all the
stuff that's you know coming in straight
off the application that he's got to
turn something useful for other parts of
the organization
then there's Ned Ned is the business
analyst and he needs a lot of aggregated
data right things that he can use to
generate statistics and understanding
about how the business is performing not
just again rows or log files but again
that next level up from sort of the
basics and then finally we have Jan the
app developer she's gonna need users and
product predictions or recommendations
she's gonna be able to she needs to be
able to build you know new micro
services that expose things like this
recommendation engine to the end user so
that can be things like a
recommendations API access to wish lists
you know some knowledge around similar
users or similar products how things
complement each other but you can see
there's a little bit of overlap here but
not a ton right they all need something
different and they kind of need it in a
slightly different format if you think
about sort of a I tried to draw a
sequence diagram here and it got a
little complicated so I I simplified a
little bit but ultimately Alice and Bob
have to agree and talk to each other Bob
and Ned have to agree and talk to each
other meta analysis talks to each other
and Jann and Alice have to talk to each
other you know there's a lot of
communication happening and listen I
love talking to my co-workers just as
much as the next person but if you're
spending all of your time trying to
explain to them what you need when you
need it where it came from what it
should look like it becomes challenging
right it slows down the ability for them
to make progress and work quickly
all right ultimately this is the problem
that we see a lot of folks having out in
the world right
they each have to find data sets they
each have to figure out who owns it they
have to figure out how things are
related to each other and they have to
manage all that by themselves which
again takes time away from their
ultimate task just by a show of hands
does this sound familiar to anybody oh
that's a scary number actually maybe I
should have asked that question now this
is but this is great right this is how
we have to we have to find you know
understand what the problem is then try
to solve it together all right so let's
talk about tools right that's the first
step we need to understand what
everyone's working with in order to kind
of make the next jump so Alice is data
scientist a huge fan of Python like
myself it's like her Swiss Army knife
she uses it for just about everything
typically does a lot of her work with
ipython or Jupiter notebooks right pulls
data down doesn't honor workstation you
know slices dices data uses a lot of
pretty common data science frameworks
uses things like numpy scifi
scikit-learn pandas because she has a
history of our you know likes data
frames that's a typical approach from a
data science perspective Bob is a huge
fan of Java right he does lots of big
ETL pipeline work does a lot of
orchestrating data from one format to
another or multiple sources of data
together into something that looks
cohesive on the other end
so he's typically using tools like
MapReduce or spark in some cases you
might be using Apache beam which will
actually hear more about over the next
couple days as well Ned is like a
spreadsheet guy right he loves sequel
and he loves spreadsheets so what he
likes to do was build custom reports and
dashboards very sequel driven got to
have some kind of access to a data
warehouse we can do giant you know kind
of cube rotations and understanding
basically he's got to be able to prove
to the business how products are
performing why things like a
recommendation is even necessary
recommendation engine is even necessary
so it's his responsibility to kind of
facilitate that and then we've got Jan
the up developer Jansen typical kind of
polyglot app developer likes writing
stuff and micro-services likes
delivering features very quickly you
know may have a language preference one
way or the other but has to maintain a
lot of the existing infrastructure so
that could be things like node apps it
could be
simple things like Python apps with
flask or ruby apps with Sinatra all the
way up to like kitchen sink frameworks
like Django or rails just depends right
wherever the use cases all right so
we've gotten that far so we understand
their tasks we know who all the key
players are and we know the things that
they like to use so the next step for us
is how do we figure out which tools they
should be using in Google Cloud all
right
so what we'll do is let's lay out a
handful of the tools that are available
and we're not going to cover everything
that's in GCP right now because we don't
have enough time and I want you guys to
have snacks at some point soon so what
we'll do is kind of focus on the core
set of things that are critical for each
of those individual roles to kind of
have access to so the first part you
know for things like applications we've
got compute so with things like virtual
machine or virtual instances with
compute engine managed kubernetes
clusters with container engine or just
kind of manage container deployments or
docker container deployments with App
Engine right it's a good place to start
on the storage front cloud storage for
objects cloud sequel for relational data
cloud datastore for you know no sequel
or non-relational data sets and a cloud
BigTable for wide column and then on the
data and analytics or than the more
processing kind of side data proc for
managed to dupe and spark clusters data
lab for ipython notebooks bigquery for
kind of an analytical data warehouse and
data flow for running managed beam
Apache beam pipelines and then the last
column over the last kind of group is
machine learning so we've got a cloud
machine learning which is kind of
running you know tensorflow models and
running them at scale things like the
natural language API
the speech API or the vision API as you
start to think about the team that we
just introduced and you start looking at
this sort of bucket of tools of this you
know the set of puzzle pieces you can
start to see where things are going to
kind of fit together right there's a
consistent set of tools here that we can
map back onto the team so let's walk
through each one of those individually
really quickly alright so for data
science workloads Alice has a couple of
options right she we already talked
about the fact that she's a fan of
Python so that map's really well so with
Python she has two options she can
either use cloud data lab or
you can use cloud data proc with Jupiter
with data lab what she gets is a
complete Python dev environment you know
it's bundled in with like none PI scipy
matplotlib so she can kind of kick off
her work and build those charts and
build those kind of understanding around
the data center she would additionally
on top of that though it's also got
built-in support for a tensor flow and
bigquery this means she's got a complete
environment to go and start maybe
prototyping models if she wants to build
with tensorflow if she's trying to build
a very compelling recommendation
mechanism or if she needs data that
lives in bigquery she can actually do
inline sequel statements there and pull
data back out or offload queries to
bigquery as well so she's got a handful
of options there the nice thing about
data lab is that it's based on Jupiter
so it's got a little bit of background
so it should look very familiar to her
but it is somewhat you know sort of
constrained on to just Python if she's
got more specific needs or wants to
include additional frameworks or kernels
then we have to look at something like
cloud data proc + Jupiter so what you
can do is you can spin up a Cloud Data
proc cluster right again a managed yarn
cluster effectively and then have
Jupiter pre-installed on there and ready
to go so it takes about you know 90
seconds to fire up a Hadoop cluster
anywhere from like three to like a
couple thousand nodes in this case for
Alice I think just three nodes is
probably appropriate and her goal is to
just spin this up and get you pa'dar
pre-installed once she's got Jupiter
then she's back to like the exact same
environment she had on her laptop right
support for like over 80 different
languages and frameworks or kernels but
the nice thing also is built-in support
for pi spark and spark ml tip so you
know if you're if you're kind of trying
to figure out where the machine-learning
line sort of follows there's definitely
a handful of more sessions you can
attend around things like tensor flow or
on data proc what I would urge you I
thought to do is if you've got kind of
an individual like this in your
organization is have them explore both
right tensor flow might be appropriate
spark ml lid might be appropriate and
there's a you know there should be a
clean distinction between what they can
each do all right on the data processing
front same thing right Bob's got a
couple different options he can either
use Cloud Data proc or he can use cloud
data flow with data proc again we just
talked about this briefly but managed to
dupe and spark clusters
the nice thing about about data proc and
I'm only going to spend a minute on this
so by all means if you're interested we
can do questions afterwards but the nice
thing about data proc is that it turns
that kind of mindset of a Hadoop cluster
or a young Carn cluster on its head you
end up going away from having a cluster
centric view of the world and turning it
into more of a job centric view of the
world so instead of firing up a thousand
node cluster that everybody shares you
could have every individual job have
their own thousand node cluster and as
long as those jobs can be done in less
than 24 hours you can actually take
advantage of things like pre-owned to
below VMs or preemptable instances those
instances are about 80% off list price
so you get the ability to do this job
dramatically faster than ever before
because you have all this extra compute
sitting around and you could do it
really cheaply because it only takes a
few hours anyway so Bob's got that
option he could also do things like you
know tune the cluster parameters or if
he's got custom jar files he needs
easily bootstrap those across the
cluster doesn't matter right he has that
option the other approach is to use
dataflow dataflow is a managed service
that we have for running Apache beam
workloads Apache beam is basically a
programming model or an approach that
unifies batch and stream processing into
one when you take beam workloads or beam
pipelines and you push them to cloud
dataflow we run those for you in a
totally managed kind of automatically
scalable map fashion so that's pretty
nice and Apache beam workloads on cloud
dataflow actually support templates for
kind of like easy parameterization and
staging and things like that the way I
kind of think about the relationship
here of which paths you go down is
really a question of what do you have
existing already right if you've got a
huge investment in spark or MapReduce
jobs or just in kind of like easy
workflows around those things by all
means go down the Cloud Data proc route
it's a turnkey solution you can take
your job and just push it to a new
cluster just like that if it's net new
when you're starting from scratch
I think beam is a good approach to look
to look at it's relatively new so it's
still a little bit young it's definitely
not as mature as as some of the other
components in the Hadoop ecosystem but
it does have this really really really
critical advantage where you can take a
batch
pipeline and turn to a streaming
pipeline just by changing a couple of
lines of input so Bob's got a couple of
options here to kind of match up to what
he typically likes to work with all
right ned's use case is actually really
simple
he needs a data warehouse he needs a
data warehouse that supports sequel and
that could scale with whatever size of
data he needs or word that he's got
access to and he's gotta be able to plug
it into a whole host of tools kind of
downstream so big queries a great fit
for him right
Enterprise Cloud analytical data
warehouse right it's a fully managed
mechanism we often use the word server
listen I hate that term so I apologize
it's support standard sequel and it does
scale up to kind of petabyte scale right
so he has the option of running
something that's anywhere from data sets
that's data sets that are about
gigabytes all the way up to petabytes
and still get responses back within
seconds bigquery is great because it
does support kind of batch loading or
streaming inserts as well and it's got
built-in things like security and
durability and automatic availability
and all the other good stuff but
ultimately the best part is that Ned
gets to use sequel gets the query really
really large data sets and visualize and
explore the data as he's used to with
the with the typical tools and expertise
he's got when it comes time to create
reports and dashboards and things like
that there's a couple of options he has
one he can use data studio which is
built into the platform so it's kind of
like a Google Doc style approach where I
can create a new report and then I can
share that with everybody in the company
without actually him to create multiple
copies and people can edit things like
parameters and watch the difference in
those reports and and see how they look
but effectively he has the ability to
create those reports and dashboards
alternatively he could use things like
tableau or look or other business
intelligence tools that he's that he's a
fan of so he's got a handful of options
there the nice thing also is that
because of all this approach like
bigquery also supports others kind of
JDBC infrastructure so a lot of the
tooling that net is typically used to
can plug right into bigquery as well
all right so the last one is jann right
we talked about this earlier jan likes
to deploy and scale micro services so
she's got two easy options there if
she's really really focused on complex
container orchestration rights then once
the deploy thing is that way container
engine is a great fit it's based on open
source kubernetes we've got built-in
health checking monitoring log
we've got a private container registry
or she can go down the app engine room
and just take her doctor containers and
push them up and we'll autoscale them
for the good thing is that along with
you know kind of the same health
checking monitoring and logging App
Engine also includes you know a built-in
load balancer up front has things like
version management traffic splitting as
well and automatic security scanning so
a good a couple of options here that
kind of makes sense for her all right so
that's it right we're all done
everybody's got tools they can all work
in there everybody's often you know off
to the races that's not true right we've
only just kind of scratched the surface
so they all have a consistent set of
tools to work with but we actually
haven't enabled any of the collaboration
bits yet so we still have to figure out
how to get them not only to work
together but actually to work in a way
that makes sense and scales up right
their team is four people today it could
be eight twelve sixteen you know in a
few weeks so we've got to kind of come
up with a better approach to managing
the data that they need access to all
right so if you're trying to enable
collaboration there's there are a
handful of things you're really going to
think about the first is you've got to
find consistency and it's not just
consistency in you know in the tool set
right that's that's also important but
you also need consistency in terms of
where do you expect data to be coming
from where do you expect data to be used
downstream right that's really important
if you can't agree on the sources if you
can't agree on what the sort of
downstream workloads are it's hard to
really understand how everybody should
work together and use the same set of
tools the next thing you want to do is
take a really good hard look at all the
data that you're trying to get access to
and this isn't true for every piece of
data losing organization right it might
be things that are focused on certain
sets of the company like certain teams
or certain tasks but ultimately you've
got to figure out where all this data
lives and take an inventory on it right
take an inventory on it and make sure
it's in the right storage medium for
everyone to use as time goes on the next
thing you want to do is come up with an
approach around metadata right this is
pretty simple but you know if you're
trying to figure out who owns a piece of
data or you know where it came from what
other data sets are it's related to what
are some of the
of data that are located in this data
set without having actually having to go
query it that's a really challenging
problem to do when you you know when you
think about having hundreds or thousands
of individual pieces of data spread out
across your infrastructure then you want
to enable discovery and self-service you
want people to be able to go find these
things by themselves and pull them down
as needed without having to go again
spend all that time arguing with people
about formats and you know availability
and tooling and bring them up swear
you're gonna store it as well and then
the last thing is security right don't
keep that on the table it's certainly
important understand security and more
broadly identity right to make sure
we're tracking access to all these
things all right so how do we start with
this
you know I throw this in there you have
to kind of embrace the concept of a data
Lake I'm not suggesting you have to go
build one I know it's a totally loaded
buzzword and term but you have to build
something you have to embrace the idea
of it on some level right and this is
kind of what I said earlier if you start
at the very bottom you first have to
understand what are all the sources of
data I've got right at least get
everybody to agree in the room where
data is coming in from and not what it
looks like once you do that you want to
find some again consistency on which
tools are we gonna use to store data
you're not gonna consume every single
part of the platform right it doesn't
make sense to just use every service
because it's there find the ones that
make the most sense for the data that
you've got and we'll go through that in
a second as well and the last thing is
what are the use cases right how is the
data going to get used over time right
it's important that you understand what
those use cases are because they're
gonna drive back to the data to the
storage mediums and it's important to
pick the storage mediums because that's
going to depend pretty heavily on how
the data comes in where it comes from
and what it looks like all right so
where should data live right we know the
sources we know the workloads but what
do we do in the middle there how do we
figure out which places to put data so
this is kind of a simple decision tree
and I'll go into a little bit more depth
on the next slide as well but some of
this you can kind of simplify right if
it's really structured data right you're
kind of down to two options is it sort
of you know OLTP data or is it OLAP data
right is it transactional or is it
analytical if it's transactional cloud
sequel is a great fit right it's a
typical relational database no
frills does what it does and it doesn't
really well on the analytical side you
have bigquery right so you it depends on
what the use case is right that's
starting to derive it not just the
structure but what the use case is the
next column is semi structure right so
you've got something that you might know
the schema for but it could change right
it could adapt in flight people might be
deploying new mobile apps somewhere that
customers are going to use they're gonna
start capturing data they weren't
capturing before all those things are
possible so if you've got you know semi
structured data then it's a question of
how do I need to query that data right
again we're back to what is the
downstream use case if it's something
where you need to query on any possible
field that you write in datastore is a
good choice right when you write a piece
of JSON to cloud datastore we
automatically index every key by default
that's part of that JSON now you can
turn that off if you want to you can
pick the keys you want but ultimately
you have the ability to query anything
that you've written in there whereas
when you put data into big table you're
basically stuck with trying to have
query by the row key and that's actually
pretty powerful for a lot of really
great you know for a lot of use cases
especially like time series data or
transactional data but it's not a great
fit again if you want to try to query
some random column you know somewhere
buried throughout the data set and the
last one is object right images media
that sort of thing that just goes
straight into cloud storage so it's a
pretty simple approach so if you break
this out a little bit and start getting
a few more examples you kind of end up
with a chart that looks like this right
we just covered object storage really
quickly a second ago
great for binary data great for object
data media backups that sort of thing on
the non-relational side for cloud
datastore it's really good for
hierarchical data right again think of
like JSON is a good example there to fit
in there obviously great on like mobile
applications that sort of thing on the
BigTable side really really powerful
system for heavy reads and writes but
you have the row key only as your only
option there's a little bit of filtering
you can apply outbound on it query but
really it's driven by the row key so
you've got a very specific workload you
can you can use out of BigTable on the
relational side you have two options
right and I mentioned I didn't mention
spanner yet and it's still early on
spanner but I did want to put it into
context for kind of for everybody in the
room class equals great for web
frameworks right typical
applications that you're gonna build
typical credit applications are great
spanners really interesting it's it's
new for us right it's still it's still
early right spanner hasn't gone into
general availability quite yet but it's
an interesting thing to keep an eye on
especially as people are building kind
of global facing applications where
their customers could be just about
anywhere and having you know a mechanism
that has a globally distributed sequel
infrastructure it's really powerful so
it's something to keep your eye on as
you kind of make more progress with GCP
and the last one is you know warehouse
data right data warehouse bigquery
that's the right place to put that so
this is where it gets interesting
you found the tools you found the
sources and you found the workloads how
do you continue on this path of enabling
self-service and discovery so you've got
to take you know you've taken all the
data sets we've taken inventory of all
of them they're all located in the right
places but there might be a lot of it so
how do we enable people to actually find
the things they're looking for over time
and this is where metadata is really
important right because I think we're
you know if you guys can kind of guess
where I'm going
ultimately we're gonna do is we're gonna
try to build a catalog and that catalog
is what's gonna drive
everyone's usage downstream and
everyone's ability to work on their own
so in order to build the catalog though
you've got to agree on metadata and
actually as it turns out fortuitously or
fortunately I should say the Google
research team actually just published an
interesting blog post about facilitating
discovery of public datasets and in it
they cover things like ownership
provenance the type of data that's
located or that's contained within the
data set you know are their
relationships repeating at various data
sets can you get you know consistent
representations can you standardize some
of the descriptive tools you would use
to do it it's basically just JSON right
there's nothing fancy about this but it
forces everyone to come up and say I
have a consistent representation of
every single data set so you can start
to imagine if you have a hundred data
set strewn across the company you're
only saying to everybody listen you know
if you are an owner of a data set just
publish this small little JSON file and
hand it over to us and now we can start
cataloging this data and that's really
powerful what's even better is if you've
got that JSON data we've already had a
place to put it right so you have two
options here you can either push push
that
data into cloud datastore or into
bigquery and I'll kind of cover the
difference here cloud datastore is a
great place for this data for a variety
of reasons write it again JSON is really
well represented you can query about any
possible field there but the downside is
that datastore doesn't really have kind
of a good user facing UI right it's very
much application centric so if you want
to go ahead and build like a little
credit API on top of this thing
datastore could be a good fit the other
option is frankly bigquery you know the
same idea around datastore and storing
JSON in fact this is an example this
screenshot is an example of what this
JSON looks like in bigquery because it
does support nested columns big craze
great because you've got a UI attached
to it right there's a console right
there so you can actually run sequel
queries on it and sequel is relatively
Universal across a lot of folks they
understand it really easily so this
might make a little bit more sense to be
totally fair you know totally honest
with you guys when I typically recommend
this approach I often will push people
to bigquery as a place to kind of build
this data catalog around because it just
makes sense and it plugs into a lot of
downstream tools datastore can make
sense but it's very very particularly
dependent on how the team wants to work
for trying to find kind of a good
generic solution to start with bigquery
is a great fit so once you've done that
you've pushed right we've inventoried
we've catalogued we've got metadata and
we've got everything living inside a big
curry now so how does this change the
workflow I'm only going to pick on one
cuz they're all gonna start looking a
little bit similar if I keep if I keep
beating through it but let's talk about
the data science workflow so for Alice
now instead of having to go talk to Bob
or go talk to Ned or go talk to Jan or
talk to anybody else in the company
about what data is out there that she
can use the first thing she can do is
start to query the catalog so she can
just drop into the bigquery UI and run a
simple sequel query and explore the
datasets that she has access to the next
thing she can do because what you know
part of what's in there one of the
pieces of metadata is what is the URL or
what is the download location for this
she can go ahead and pull that data into
her environment again whether she's
running a cloud data lab notebook or a
Jupiter notebook she can pull that data
into her environment and then she can
start to prototype like a tensor flow
model for example she could start
building a little bit of a tensor flow
model and running some early and now
as measuring how well her recommendation
engine might be working once she does
that she might have created some new
data sets right she might have actually
taken something and said now I actually
have training data and test data to work
against so now that if she's created
tune of data sets the next thing she's
gonna do is upload those to the catalog
right the metadata push that in so now
other people that might want to build
this stuff later on have access to the
same training and test data that she
used all right so we're starting to
create this kind of lifecycle around
around making sure that if you create
something new make sure it gets shared
with everybody as quickly as possible
and then she's gonna continue on her
work like she normally does so trainer
machine learning models she might push
that tensorflow model to like the cloud
ml service and then because the cloud ml
service that she created is actually you
know a data kind of a resource she can
actually create a catalog entry for that
service so now if someone says I want to
find a recommendation service within the
catalog as long as she's tagged and
labeled everything appropriately they
could find the URL for that service
immediately and this is a bit of a
simplification or oversimplification of
the amount of work it takes to do all
this but if you start to extrapolate
these steps out she's been able to work
at her own pace without having to worry
about trying to find who owns what who
has access to what what she has access
to because she we built this data Khalid
we've built this approach to metadata
over time we're kind of getting to this
point where we can start building again
towards self-service so just like we
have a sequel a great sequel interface
for querying that data catalog you might
want to you know continue down the
self-service path and say can we make
these things even more discoverable can
we put like a credit API on top of this
so one option is you know to take a to
take a small application or a small
credit API that sits in front of this
bigquery metadata catalog and deploy
that in like compute engine or App
Engine or container engine and front it
with like Cloud endpoints the reason you
might go down this road is is
particularly around like you know good
API management and building again
consistent and and clear access because
the best way you can enable sort of
self-service is obviously giving
everybody access to it but also giving
everybody access to it in a way that is
most beneficial to them so if you've got
a lot of folks who are very API driven
or want to build new applications all
the time you know having an API endpoint
that they can hit to learn more about
the data catalog is very is very
beneficial an overtime you can actually
start to extrapolate this step even
further and start fronting all of the
data sources you've got so not only do
you have a credit API in front of the
catalog but you might actually have one
in front of every single data set so now
again you're you're enabling this
further
you know deeper level of access to data
and this might be a little bit overkill
for the team of four people but imagine
if that was a team of 400 or 500 people
right as you think about this kind of
approach permeating the entire
organization everyone wants to have
access and you've got to start building
these things for scale over time so
picking the right tools upfront lets you
kind of adopt that and again let's new
teams pick this approach up as well
before we finish this I do want to talk
a little bit about security early
security identity in a kind of a broad
sense we've got a great set of identity
and access management tools called cloud
I am there's a ton of sessions about it
throughout the next couple days so I
urge you guys if you're interested to go
dig into it what I really want to cover
here though is this idea that there's
policy inheritance that goes from the
top all the way to the bottom that means
at any level if you set a policy on data
access or control it does filter all the
way down so if you've got an
organization or like a single project
that's kind of the host project in your
in your project account with GCP and
you've got individual projects for like
maybe dev staging QA that sort of thing
our production and then you have
individual resources underneath those
projects you can actually control who
has access to what as long as you set
your organization up correctly I'm not
gonna go too deep here but basically the
idea to walk away with is we have the
ability to control who can see what and
who can pull things down and that's
really what you want to control yeah and
for example if you dig into bigquery a
little bit we've got a handful of roles
and different responsibilities or
different access controls that they've
got based on that stuff
so as you look at kind of what if you
look at it and think about what it's
gonna take to build sort of for the
future you know I put the slide up again
because it's really important if you do
nothing else if you build nothing else
you have to get agreement right that's
the most important thing if you can't
kind of adopt this idea that we have to
have consistency around data sources
data workloads and then the tools we're
gonna use to work with that data this is
gonna be a long road right as much as I
talked about like the the products and
the blue hexagons and stuff a lot of
this is a cultural kind of shift and an
organization right it's kind of a
lifestyle change you have to get
everybody on the same page and part of
doing that is saying can we add
consistence here can we make this a
consistent view of the world that we can
all agree upon and this you know might
be a small subset of what you end up
with it could be a much much larger
picture with a lot more pieces to it but
it's important that everybody agrees
again what the data is gonna what kind
look like coming in what its gonna get
used for on the way out and where it's
gonna live while it's sitting in your
infrastructure as you think about you
know as you kind of get through that
consistency piece and you know that's a
tough road but once you get through that
then the next step is really getting
around to building the catalog right can
you catalog all the data sets do you
know exactly what lives throughout the
organization can you can you you know
get everyone to kind of pony up and say
all you have to do is write this little
snippet of JSON and we'll be able to
leave you alone for the next few days
right if you can build the catalog
that's a great first step then the next
thing you want to do is make sure your
teams have access to the tools they need
to do this work right and this is not
just you know the tools that are in GCP
but it's also like the API access or the
sequel access to the data sets can they
get those things have you set up like
identity and understanding the security
correctly so that everybody has access
because what you want people to be able
to do is work on their own without
having to go bother anywhere else if
they can do everything they need to do
without interacting with somebody else
then when they do interact and they go
have lunch together it's a lot
friendlier conversation as opposed to
arguing about who has access to data
[Music]
you